so i am willing to entertain the idea
that
we are witnessing um
[Music]
that the nature of the great change that
is about to overtake us is our language
is about to go from something we hear to
something we see
and that this is going to bind us
as a community more tightly than we have
ever been bound before
to see what i mean analyze ordinary
communication
i have a thought
i
it's
it's pre-verbal it's amorphous but
something goes on in my brain and i map
it on to my vocabulary
i then download that through my voice
box and i
create an acoustical signal which is
simply a
pressure wave in the air
it passes through the air from my mouth
to your ears
and you take it in
and you have a dictionary which your
culture has given you
and here we make an enormous leap of
faith
the leap of faith is we assume that your
dictionary and my dictionary
are the same edition published by the
same company
and so
you reconstruct my thought
out of your dictionary and lo and behold
my thought
takes root in your mind having crossed
the intervening physical space well the
first problem here is what i call the
spaghetti of ambiguity
your dictionary is not like my
dictionary if i were to suddenly begin
speaking wii toto
my thoughts could be sublime and
brilliantly composed but you would say
he lost me because you have no skills in
witoto whatsoever
and it is only a cultural convention
that we share the same
dictionary one of the most uncool things
you can do in a social situation is say
to someone
would you um
explain to me what i just said
and unless we're at the level of where
are the car keys or get me a latte
please
it's going to turn out to be astonishing
how far variant they are i deal with
this all the time because talks like
this are tape recorded and then given to
some poor typist somewhere and it is
expected of this person that they will
produce a transcript of what i said
and i get these transcripts
and the most amazing malapropism
are there where in a struggle to make it
make sense they supposed what i was
saying and just missed it completely and
often it's very humorous
these kinds of things so our illusion of
communication is simply that if i were
to read to you a little paragraph from
malaresha to temper do or any work of
depth
we could then spend the rest of the
morning talking about what does the
author mean
you know the ambiguity of of text but if
we were to have a piece of sculpture
in front of us
we
are much more
tightly focused in the same dimension we
who observe it you don't see a different
piece of sculpture than i do i mean to
some degree but not much where in
confrontation with text i may understand
a piece of text perfectly and the
content of it may change my life and
when i ask you what it means you say
well i don't know it's some kind of
verbage this guy couldn't parse a
sentence i couldn't make anything out of
it it just
needs to get a life
so i think that
it's amazing that our global
civilization
is knitted together by nothing more than
small mouth noises
small mouth noises delivered at about 50
hertz
you know 50 cycles per second
and our machines which are now our
prosthesis and which are knitting our
world here they operate at 400 megahertz
and up
uh
literally two orders of magnitude faster
the information is being transferred and
it can be digitalized it can be visual
so
and there's even physiological evidence
for this
for example well i talked about
ayahuasca and how you see sound under
the influence of ayahuasca well
ayahuasca runs on harmolin and dmt
dmt occurs in the brain the human brain
under ordinary metabolic circumstances
and harmine
it turns out occurs in this most
mysterious of all brain
neighborhoods the pineal gland
in the pineal gland is a compound called
a denero adeniroglomerotropine
but when you deconstruct it as a
physical chemist you discover its
5-methoxy no 6-methoxy
tetrahydroharmalan it's an analog of
harmine
and so i i think that
there is evolution
going on in our species very subtle
evolution toward ever more
inclusive speech and that the
physiological
strategy for achieving this
is uh
to shunt the language processing
uh function out of the acoustical domain
and into the visual domain and then all
these technologies which we're building
simply synergize
set in place and make
more inevitable this tendency toward
visual
explicitness and
virtual reality then
coming along
is sort of the cherry on the cake
because you know there are many things
you can do with virtual reality uh
plan
the kitchen of the house you're building
compare carpets swatches and all these
trivial things but if you step back and
analyze it what vr is
is a technology for showing each other
the contents of our own head
you know an artist who spends a year
building a virtual reality is freezing
a hallucinogenic mind space
previously utterly private previously
incommunicable
by any means and then you just put the
goggles on to someone and say here is my
vision walk through it
take a look
look as long as you like take your time
and so
what has always been private and hidden
and
only
to be shared
through simulacrums in verbal speech
now becomes a shared modality
and this is going to again overcome the
idea of our differences and our our
islanded uniqueness as an ego and so i
think inevitably the the
key word that hovers over the future is
collectivism
connectivity
telepathy
shared understanding
[Music]
you